We come to nimbin for peace and happiness and how many in our lives and. The way that we divided the labor.
In those early days of. Building our homes and establishing gotten was really directed towards peace and harmony and.
The difficulties that would have ensued from doing it the other way around
and having the women trying to build the house and the men inside going after the kids.
That would not have been a harmonious situation. This didn't in any way.
Of a lay the deep suspicion of the city feminists that we just full in for the old line and.
You know that we were really not creating any sort of alternative atoll. But from up point of view.
It was a more harmonious way of living a life so i think i can't speak for all my sisters in that regard
but certainly for me. It didn't feel too bad and i did have a go at clearing a site and starting to build something.
And within a very short space of time. I was weeping over the magic. I do you know just feeling totally incompetent.
Now there will women who who have built houses and. One woman built a stone house at the top of a cliff.
From stunning that she had to get up there somehow
and she devised a flying fox to carry the materials up to the sunlight. An extraordinary feat of engineering.
And another woman. Not any built.
Oh i think by now she's built several houses but in the in the early time of paradise valley she built her first home.
And subsequently went on to teach other women. In a women's building course and also taught aboriginal women.
In a building course. So that's not to say that you know.
There weren't women who became builders that would quite a few.
But as i say in the early days it was it was mainly the men who did that sort of work and. Mostly the.
That was that was ok. The ways in which of cool so you know i mean the guys that came to live a ton of would just gone.
You know and the women were just women
and we all came with the conditioning that we'd all had no different from the rest of society.
But with to have a little more will to move past our conditioning. And establish new values and customs for us selves.
So that the aim of that was ready to help each other rather than to confront each other constantly which would have
just been a constant battle. I think we were aiming for. What how can we cooperate how can we live together better.
And there were many ways in which we tried to achieve that and the women's group was particularly supportive of women.
You know who either wanted. In their relationship. To improve their status as women.
Or who felt that their status was so far from any hope of improvement in the relationship that they were in that they
were supported then to get out of that relationship because it was seen as being destructive and harmful.
And i guess for that reason at all for a lot of relationships actually didn't survive and.
I do think was that was partly because women were supported to leave. Relationships that was stifling them.
So if very much so. Although it was affected too.
You'd think twice before leaving any sort of a shelter because there wasn't another one to go to easily and.
But because i suppose there were very few women and quite a lot of guys. And probably about three to one.
And in the first few years of tangible.
It was a little easier for women to find support not only among the women friends
but also from other guys outside of her relationship. And it didn't work the other way.
And that led to an awful lot of loneliness. Particularly among the guys who were there. Without patents and and.
Really belied the myth that. The nimbin.
Alternative society was about six drugs
and rock'n'roll because it was not as much about six as people might have supposed.
The fact that we all ran around stark naked which we did. Had nothing to do with that.
Well certainly as far as i was concerned it didn't it may have in the minds of some people but it really you know.
In a way that was a kind of incest to boo. Operating with was so close to living together and such close quote is that.
To run through a series of highly charged sexual relationships with one's. Brothers and sisters.
Could have actually been destructive to the to the survival of the community and.
You know i don't know how conscious that was but i observed that it didn't happen.
That there weren't a series of highly charged six your relationships that.
One relationship might be breaking down and another one. Might be passionately starting up. But it was.
It wasn't rife through the community or. You know sort of a total sort of day night loving as.
Is the media might have liked to put try it. Despite the fact that we never had any clothes on it very much so.
And in fact i think. Had it not been for my. Tribal experience of nimbin.
I may not have gone on to be as interested in other tribal cultures as i am but. Subsequently i spent a great deal of.
Time with the rainforest tribes and sort of like in borneo. And particularly with the tribes and.
There is ways of living. Exhibit often very much the same sort of qualities and i'm noticed also with some.
Aboriginal tribal people and north american indians to the.
Probably the most important things is if everybody has such a similar level of poverty. It's not really.
Fessor was not really experience just pull for tea then it's. Anything that is. Extra to your very basic.
Provisions is is a treat and everybody's really excited about that. But also. You'll share anything.
If everyone's really pull you'll share anything with anyone.
There's no that's mine and you can have it sort of feeling. And that's true throughout tribal societies and.
It's more true in truly. Tribal societies and it wasn't name been in those days but there were elements of that.
That that. You know. There was there would always be a welcome and refreshments and. You know.
Hospitality even for total strangers who arrived it turned that some way they'd always find a warm welcome
and a sense of community as soon as they cut that and. That's it that's a very tribal. Thing and.
A kind of integrity and. A trust and. A lack of a strange a feeling.
You know that you are a stranger and somebody else is a stranger there's a kind of. Dismal openness and trust.
Accepting people exactly as you find them at that moment. And not.
Sort of projecting a whole lot of fear of suspicion on to them. And that tended to be.
You know the way that we operated it. And all that everyone was ok. And if they prove themselves to be otherwise well.
We just knew more about them then. You know. And i think that's. That's a fairly tribal sort of thing and.
Despite what i said earlier about their ways of bringing up children. Still within the tribal setting.
There were more advantages for children than disadvantages to the tribal way of bringing up children in the sense that.
Adults would have a sense of responsibility. As much for other people's children as for their own.
Now that might have come back to a lowest common denominator that they didn't have much sense of responsibility for
anyone's children but the children will survive i mean none of them actually sort of drowned in the creek.
And so that there was a sense that there were other eyes and ears and uncles and aunties out there.
And if you kids were in difficulty that they'd be somebody they could call on even if you weren't nearby.
That was a good feeling and and a tribal feeling. But i think mostly that the sense of a tribal. Experience came.
When we came together for celebrations and dances and. Events.
Could have been an event centered around a spiritual activity such as a naming ceremony for children or.
A retreat tool. Or something of that sort or it could have been just a full moon down so it blew no poll.
It could have been anything but when we all came together. And sore each other there. In.
You know dressed in whatever we addressed in silks and satins and colors
and all that sort of stuff in celebrates removed. Then the tribal sense was exquisite.
Just excludes it and it still it still survives now even though it was scattered through the hills
and the rainbow region is extended far beyond. The boundaries of nimbin.
When we do see each other at different events may be a bar and buy or even in sydney or somewhere else that. Sense of.
Oh we together again. Is is really wonderful. And now it's interesting because we often.
I find lots of different people we sort of make jokes about how we're all going to end up in the same old hippies home
somewhere. And i mean that it's a joke now.
Because we're in our mid forty's but actually twenty years down the track if we keep meeting like this you know.
We know what's going to happen. And it could well be that. This is a wonderful eccentric old hippies.
And there's a part of me that really hopes that will be. Well if i can i was one of the very earliest.
Sort of institutions of naming i mean there were many and many have survived to the present day
but the folk i was particularly special because there was so many people who came.
Who had music as part of the background and. One of the things that they really love to do either as a as a you know.
A player or a listener.
And the folk cover rose out of that and a rose also out of the fact that a number of those people.
They might have had classical training and.
All sorts of training and education in music but a lot of them were into writing. Original material and.
Which is not particularly commercial perhaps but. Incredibly enjoyable and.
So we had a weekly event where you know it was just a kind of jam session or. You know people wouldn't. Would play.
One at a time or into trios or whatever and then all get together at the end. For whatever happened and.
It was it was an extra. Event. Every time it happened. I mean sometimes it was the most astonishing music.
You know and people you got to be very famous we had people who sort of had played. The sydney opera house.
You know playing.
Believe a billy strange medieval instruments you know the night before
and the next night found themselves in nimbin playing to a naming crowd and getting you know.
And even a response in in the night go to the opera and.
We did and we had a magic drawing of all sorts of people who came through and.
One of the most healing events from them been in the early days when there was still quite a bit of suspicion
and difficulty between the old cyclists and the new people who'd come to town and.
Slim dusty was in town and was invited to to play at the folk.
And and agreed to do that
and it was just trying to test it because he was the hero of the country people who'd lived there forever and.
You know particularly the sort of middle aged country women who lived at newman at that time you know just a team they
were absolutely ecstatic slim dusty fans. Quite on a shame they'd let you know. Really amazing. And.
And we organized a night where half of it was slim dusty and his daughter petrik and their band.
And putting on a fantastic totally professional show for nothing. You know.
And the rest of it was the name in folk club saying this in the best of up a full month and. Who organized.
Some special material for the night to. To really share with the old cyclists.
What it was that brings us together and keeps us together and to let them have a glimpse of that.
And let them know that they will welcome and to share in it too any time and.
It was just the most wonderfully successful night. Everyone had a great time.
The close of coolest love slim dusty and what you felt so i wanted. Full to have him in their town. Going for them.
But they also really enjoyed that little peek into.
What the hippies like to do you know when they get in there on tuesday nights and have their folk club
and you know they've never ventured in before.
And that they had to tell the truth they didn't venture in much after either. But it was.
They knew a bit more about his after that. And we had a a common shared high experience which.
Amongst ourselves we were having all the time really regularly.
But with the people who'd lived here before we came we seldom got to have that sort of commonality of a high experience
that we could look back on together and say wilson had a great night and.
It was lovely to have one of that as it was very special. I never had any yeah.
I have personally never had any direct experience of hostility from. Psychos who'd been there before i came.
But i heard of many people who did and i was it was the nearest i got was when somebody. I was at the.
Bush factory one night and there was music on and. A neighbor complained very loudly about the noise and she obviously.
Hated everything about his it wasn't just the noise. At the factory that night.
Yes i did hear stories of people being shot at it when they were seen sort of.
Diving into somebodies creek with no clothes on
and there were you know i mean though it was a period of adjustment in the first five to eight years of of living there.
Of you know understanding that.
Maybe it was offensive to other people if we took our clothes off and jumped in the creek.
You know and maybe we should think about that and and. I'm referring. Yeah.
And at the same time you know it was offensive to us to see them lift a gun and shoot at anything.
You know especially us. But you know you. Even a bird or a rabbit. A lot of people would have been very upset.
So you know.
I mean we just had lifestyle differences that were bound to bring some friction
but given the number of those lifestyle differences and.
The tenacity of people on both sides to their particular way of life in some cases.
It's surprising that there wasn't more friction than there was and. I always feel like you know looking back on that.
Applauding the old seculars for the. Example of tolerance. Which i think taught us a great deal and.
When the time came for us to see.
A third wave of secular is coming to name bin who had different ideals and looked different
and acted differently from how we had. We were very hard put to it. To show as much tolerance and compassion.
As the original seculars had been when we arrived on their doorstep. Oh yeah. The study was that.
I did a study for the university of new england i think it was the geography department.
It was a land use so they
and the intention was to find out the shifting patterns of land use in various parts of new south wales i think they
had a control area somewhere else. And they were particularly interested in.
Interviewing the new settlers to nimbin and that and finding out what they were about
and what their intentions were as forgot the. Regards the use of the land.
Well i don't remember very much about what they replied in in answer to that particular question
or that set of questions but what really struck me is quite remarkable. Was that.
One of the questions that i os i had to interview i think it was ninety four hippies. Which was a. Had to do.
It was actually a lot of fun. And one of the questions that i asked the mole.
Was whether they felt themselves in coming to nimbin. To be a part of a movement. And i mean for.
Objectively you know if you took a step back and looked at it. He would ninety four people representing another.
You know several hundred who would all come around the same period of time to the same area.
Doing more or less the same sorts of things in similar ways. And you know from an objective point of view.
Would movement wouldn't be too strong a word to put on it but. A free one of them said that i'm not part of a movement.
I'm an individual this like i was completely separate from anything else that was happening and.
I found that quite astonishing
but it was actually true i mean people believed that of themselves they felt they not only felt they really experienced
themselves as making a totally individual choice. And coming to nimbin and doing a totally individual thing.
And i love the duality of that. That. Of course it was a movement.
And of course it was nothing to do with a movement it was a. You know hundreds of totally individual decisions.
I think that really appeared in my eyes is a lot about human
and it says a lot about the difficulty that we always had in making rules for communities. You know.
Tumble fulls coordination co-operative. I'd it's very first tribal meeting.
Brought up the topic of whether people should be allowed to have cats dogs and guns. On the property.
And now fifteen years later when most of the fifty eighteen. Nearly twenty years later.
This still discussing whether they can have cats dogs and guns on the property. And now and it.
All the end of inning is they have been cats and dogs and guns. And everybody's disapproved of it.
And everybody's trying to make rules about it. And it can't happen. And. So we're there. Ah levels of agreement.
I think that usually quite. Spoken. And unconscious and. Deviance from the general agreement.
In terms of environmental custody and she have been. Those sorts of. Concepts and. Beyond rules. You know.
No i don't because i feel that in a way it's success because. Rigid rules.
Actively exclude the people who will not conform to them and. In a society of non conformists. The how.
How could you possibly impose rigid rules. And not lose some of your best people to quit. It was about being active.
Being creative. Being careful and being homeless and. It was also about growing. Selves. Food. Children.
Institutions structures that we needed. That were appropriate to our needs.
But growing all those things and taking care of those things and. As much as we could of the wider picture too.
And giving something into it and putting into it somehow. Culturally.
So that involve music and dance and poetry and all sorts of. And. I suppose treading lightly on the and and.
And above all being homeless. That's what it was for me but you know.
There be as many visions as there are people here.
That he needs to go through all of this been simon a stupid hippie i did.
And long he writes deep into the night of that technology and. It's really hard to even think of one example air.
Said busy that. I kind i kind of come up with it and.
Well i shammy it intends a conspiracy theory is that it that it it's been quite a frightening thing about name it in a
way that that there's a lot of paranoia around and.
I don't know that i really want to go into that they have because it's said to us by designing a few individuals.
It's not a good. It's not a good starting point that the end. Going to that problem.
Think that's why i really didn't want to go into it because there are some people around nimbin who would be thought
disordered with or without marijuana who it actually. You know. Borderline personalities and.
That's really harry's area of the mine. It's not a good. It's not a good thing for me to talk about.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah. Well people would. Yeah yeah. Well people your people gave their children.
The names that people gave to their children were actually no funnier than the ones that they gave to themselves i mean
you know there were as many sort of stuff and. Sunnies and. Moon shines in.
Among the adult population who change their names as there were some strange and unusual names for the children and.
Of course particularly when quite a few people became divots he's of russian age.
And that's not to say that that was any kind of dominant paradigm in the community but quite a few people did.
Get into the russian a she thing and take on new names as a result of that it was impossible to remember and.
Too long and irrelevant. But that's a judgment of mine.
But the nice that was given to children of course a lot of the children. Wouldn't wouldn't keep. Days they.
Once they got to school age if the name embarrassed. Them the child would change it. I was it was a.
It was chuckle tyga. Who pretty quickly was that had to sally when she got to school and. There was another little guy.
I forget what his original name was but i remember he ended up being. He was known as d.d. His name is d.d.
and That was his name. And he became john. Very quickly. And i remember one frenchman who didn't name his child a tool.
And wouldn't give her name and.
She was three when i measure and so didn't have a name but i don't know what became of her
and close like can't remember her name. I think for me the most memorable night. Was was. Well the with several.
There was several memorable nights but there was one in particular that was a new year's eve.
Which traditionally was held. As a sort of costume bowl. A little pool and.
A hippie costume ball is something to be seen. It was really fantastic.
And on this particular night it was especially wonderful for me because i knew in advance that.
Some people are coming over from america. Whom. I greatly admire.
Stephen gaskin and his wife and i guess can who'd set up a community in tennessee called the.
I'm with him i'd been in correspondence for several years by then.
And they were coming to the area to visit i knew they would do you any day. But what actually happened was that.
We were all at the done so. You know pull on new year's eve. And stephen gaskin and i know my. Arrived just as.
Smiling ruth and. And the band. The band was cool blue skies or something.
And they just started to play the tennessee waltz and by shia coincidence stephen and on and i arrived at bruno pole.
And you know i recognized steven from a distance i was outside the whole one here.
And i was standing facing him in the moment when he first heard the music and realized what the song was.
And he realized that the tennessee waltz was being played. And i realized that he was steven gaskin from tennessee.
And then we looked at each other and we just. Had this incredible hug. But we never met before.
But it was incredibly high it was a wonderful experience. And he went on to spend a few weeks around nimbin.
And it was a great visit and. A great cultural exchange. Oh i think there are certain parts of the world.
That have a magic energy. I don't i couldn't define it any better than that.
It's an energy that you feel as you approach a place. It might. Magnetize you it could repel you i suppose.
But it's a feeling that you get about right. And name in it has a very strong spiritual place and.
I couldn't possibly define it but for me it's absolutely a mistake of believe
and i know that there are other people who experience other parts of the world as having a similar.
Vibration if you like and i think it's a.
You know it's to do with the things that have happened there the history of the place.
I don't think those sorts of emanations. Disperse. Very easily and.
You know there's a sort of cold dying canarsie feeling about.
Places where cold dank and nasty things have happened
and there's a an energetic feeling about places where energetic things have happened and.
Nimbin is certainly one of things and i've got to get it.